l état d'urgence sanitaire sera donc
rétablie à partir de samedi un
couvre-feu a été instauré on le rappelle
en ile de france et dans huit métropoles
la mesure pourrait être étendue jusqu'au
1er décembre si le parlement
l'autorisait à l'heure outre le débat
sur l'efficacité d'une telle mesure pour
freiner l'épidémie ou sur le caractère
opportun d'une éventuelle décision
politique à gauche comme à droite un
débat parlementaire est réclamée alors
le couvre-feu porte-t-il atteinte à nos
libertés individuelles la solidarité
prime tel sur nos libertés c'est l'objet
de notre face à face et pour en parler
nous sommes avec julie garnier
porte-parole la france insoumise bonsoir
à vos côtés aurélien véron conseiller de
paris porte parole du groupe changer
paris bonsoir merci à tous les deux
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors pas plus de six personnes à table
en famille interdiction des fêtes
privées des fêtes étudiantes partout en
france
un couvre-feu mis en place à paris dans
plusieurs grandes villes
comment est-ce que vous jugez ces
nouvelles mesures et ce qu'elles sont
antidémocratiques pour vous julie
garnier ces mesures elle commence
surtout à mettre en avant le fait qu'ils
sont plus enclins à faire de la
répression plutôt qu'à faire de la
prévention de l'anticipation et de la
planification
malheureusement ils font toujours peser
sur les gens ont la responsabilité que
ne prennent jamais à aucun moment ils
n'ont pris la responsabilité politique
de la crise dans laquelle nous sommes
à aucun moment ils ont fait en place
nous ce que nous proposons par exemple
de la planification ils font porter
uniquement les efforts toujours sur les
mêmes sur les gens et eux se défausse
totalement et c'est bien ça le problème
mais aurélien véron vous partagez cet
avis je trouve que le premier élément
liberticide c'est ce virus ce virus tue
ce virus contamine à grande vitesse et
donc on ne peut pas juste laisser se
propager l'épidémie on a vu ce que ça
donnait en mars et les cours sont
inquiétantes
moi je je mets de côte à côte et le la
mesure qui effectivement libertis
mais qu'il peut être utile et judicieuse
décider par elles-mêmes macron de son
discours il a un discours très utilisé
une terminologie qui - inquiète quand il
oppose les citoyens libres et se posent
des questions sur une société de
citoyens libres à des citoyens
solidaires qui l'opposent liberté à
solidarité je suis inquiet parce que
derrière cette cette improvisation on
est dans l'improvisation on est face à
un virus qui bouge le gouvernement
change son fusil d'épaulé régulièrement
en fonction de l'évolution du virus
le discours dont la trame de fond du
discours daniel mach ne me semble porter
atteinte à des valeurs fondamentales du
pays que sont en effet d'abord la
liberté
ensuite la responsabilité lorsqu'il est
fataliste et d'écouté c'est comme ça la
liberté c'est fini non je crois que la
liberté on prend des mesures qui sont
temporaires des mesures qui sont dures
des mesures graves
peut-être nécessaire mais la liberté
reste un phare dans notre modèle somme
de de penser français et il a tendance à
le piétiner un peu vite alors la treille
confie la presse couvre feu est ce que
c'est un confinement est ce que le
parlement va continuer à être absents
des décisions qui sont décrétées par le
gouvernement sans aucun débat
parlementaire et donc dans quel spirale
où on entre cette mesure qu'on tue elle
elle répond à un vrai problème mais
derrière c'est quoi ce gouvernement
qu'est-ce que jusqu'où il est prêt à
aller au nom de l'urgence pour écraser
le débat parlementaire
alors justement on va regarder les
déclarations de l'un de nos intervenants
hier soir il s'appelle denis jacquat il
est entrepreneur est pour lui le
couvre-feu après le confinement ça ne
passe pas du tout écoutez on est
définitivement et officiellement en
dictature mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à prononcer ce mot aujourd'hui en
france on a commencé par nous consignés
chez nous on a condom en continu et en
fermant les frontières je vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui au mois d'octobre les
frontières européennes sont toujours
fermés et en gros en dehors de l'europe
vingt pays ou moins dans lesquels on a
le droit de se rendre ce qui est une
première mondiale
on
jamais vu ça nulle part sauf en période
de guerre je vous rappelle juste qu'on
n'est pas en période de guerre donc on
est officiellement dictature d'autant
que dans un process démocratique vous le
savez normalement un maire qui était lui
a le pouvoir sur sa ville un président
de région sur sa région et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est à nouveau le
pouvoir central parisien qui impose sa
loi sans même concerter les élus locaux
et les élus régionaux ont même
effectivement est officiellement en
dictature des paroles fortes un de denis
jacquet vous comprenez cette opinion
julie garnier
je la comprends parce que j'ai
l'impression que nos débatteurs découvre
en fait que ce gouvernement est
liberticide avoir un virus ne l'est pas
ce sont des choix politiques qui font
qu'ils sont liberticides et le
gouvernement rails une à une les
libertés c'est garanti mme ça date pas
du virus à la liberté de manifester je
vous rappelle que aujourd'hui manifester
c'est juste un peu être un acte de
résistance
c'est ça aussi des mesures liberticides
et ça date pas d'hier ça donne pas du
virus
il ya aussi la liberté d'informer qui
aussi mise à mal dans ce pays il ya la
liberté aussi de ce syndicat qui est
mise à mal
il ya aussi le délit de solidarité qui
existe maintenant avec emmanuel macron
donc je veux dire des démos sur
liberticide y en a énormément et je
crois que ça fait un moment qu'il aurait
fallu s'inquiéter là dessus je suis un
petit peu désolé de voir que ce constat
n'arrive que maintenant
non ça fait un moment qu'il faut
s'inquiéter des libertés qui sont en
recul dans ce pays c'est bien mais bien
évidemment et je crois qu'il faut
interroger sincèrement les mesures qui
sont prises
parce qu'effectivement et ne vont pas
dans le sens de la démocratie c'est une
évidence et sa fédé ça fait des années
que ça dure
aurélien véron jeunes d'apprendre qu'une
perquisition avait lieu dans les chais
edouard philippe et au ministère la
santé
on a ce débat ce débat a lieu sur
beaucoup de l'espace médiatique
je crois que la france reste un pays
quand même où on peut s'exprimer on peut
débattre
je constate juste que la décision
présidentielle tombe une fois qu une
manière un peu brutale
même si elle se justifie moi j'ai encore
des croches qui sont hospitalisés parce
que leurs enfants ont fait la fête et
que au contact de leurs enfants et en
trapèze coville était une version encore
meurtrière il faut ne pas l'oublier
que les australiens ne pourront pas
voyagé avant 2022
de nombreux pays européens appliquent un
couvre-feu dans c'est une décision qui
est plutôt aujourd'hui en train de se
répandre en europe
l'objectif c'est de préserver une
activité économique qui permet de
financer nos hôpitaux de financer nos
infirmières de financer notre pain
quotidien de limiter ce qui a propagé le
virus cet été car nous avons quand même
constater que tous les clubs steurs
sonné de quoi de la fête de gens qui se
sont pas rendus compte que nous étions
en pleine pandémie
ils ont vécu comme si de rien n'était il
ya quand vous êtes des dizaines
assemblée dans des rues piétonnes
l'été c'est très agréable aujourd'hui on
en paye le prix
donc cette décision de couvre feu elle
n'est pas heureuse j'ai pas aimé les
mots utilisés par emmanuel macron je me
pose des questions pour l'avenir et pour
l'instant c'est une décision qui me
paraît quand même assez approprié vous
parlais tout à l'heure du recul que nous
aurions sur le co vide on a vu on a
constaté des erreurs des médecins ont
porté plainte
la perquisition a lieu suite à des
plaintes de médecins au gardien des
éléments objectifs des éléments concrets
qui montrent que le gouvernement a
commis des erreurs
il n'empêche que le confinement général
a stoppé brutalement feu est réussi
à tel point que cet été les français ont
refait la fête comme si de rien n'était
ils ont oublié que nous étions toujours
en condemi mais on est face à un virus
meurtrier dont le mois entier on a
dépassé demi longueur alors à l'échelle
de l'humanité vous allez me dire qu
telfrance insoumise que c'est c'est une
goutte d'eau non un million d'êtres
humains qu'ils soient effacées par un
virus ça nécessite des réponses fortes
des réponses coordonnées des réponses
qui évolue dans le temps en fonction du
virus ne peut pas juste croiser les
mains et dire se croiser les bras et
viraux je veux me liberté continue à
faire la fête
et puis si les seniors signé jeunes
meurent à cause de virus tant pis la
décision politique est d'abord de se
traîner d'enrayer ce virus en continuant
une activité économique
on continue on a vivement julie garnier
cette jeunesse montré du doigt assez
régulièrement
elle est irresponsable selon vous dans
ce qui a été responsable c'est à chaque
fois de pointer du doigt les
comportements individuels sans jamais
pointé du doigt le comportement du
gouvernement où il fallait des mesures
fortes
nous le disions mais ceux qui n'ont pas
pris des mesures phares que c'est bien
le gouvernement
il fallait faire du feu les mettre des
moyens dans les hôpitaux et pour les
soignants est ce qu ils l'ont fait n'ont
aucune revendication des soignants
n'a arrêté abouti avec leur fameux ses
bureaux c'est ça la réalité et ça a
conduit à quoi ça conduit à ce que
aujourd'hui un soignant sur 3 veut
démissionner ça conduit à ce qu'il y ait
moins de lits aujourd'hui qu'en mars
c'est ça la réalité c'est que ce sont
leurs choix politiques il faut aussi
qu'on est dans cette situation
et j'aimerais qu'on point de ses choix
politiques mais peut-être que vous ne
les pointes et pas parce que les auriez
fait les mêmes
juste je vous ai pas l'objectif et là je
ne traîne pas de ma région et julie
garnier vous terminez aurélien véron
vous répondant ensuite à les recruter
il aurait fallu recruter des enseignants
arrêter avec ces classes surchargées
aujourd'hui on a des classes qui sont à
plus de 30
que ce soit de la maternelle jusqu'au
lycée et je ne parle même pas de la
situation des universités ou c'est
absolument invivable c'est ça aussi
qu'il faut pointer c'est que comment
pouvez me dire que dans une classe où
ils sont 31 en maternelle on peut
maintenir à protocole sanitaire tout
simplement on ne peut pas et ça il faut
pas le nier ce sont des choix politiques
aussi qui ont été faits quand dans le
travail vous n'imposez pas le
télétravail quand vous faites en sorte
que dans les transports en commun on se
retrouve absolument dans des endroits où
on sur doivent à 10 cm les bouches des
uns et des autres c'est ça la réalité
des gens et il n'ya pas télétravail qui
a été imposée donc ce sont à chaque fois
de mettre la responsabilité sur les gens
et mettons aussi la responsabilité sur
ce qu'ils n'apprennent jamais parce que
si on en est là c'est parce qu'il ya eu
des choix politiques
ces choix politiques et fois aussi les
dénoncer nous nous posions d'autres nous
avons proposé notamment une
planification
aujourd'hui non il n'y a pas une
planification c'est pour ça que nous
sommes dans une situation
d'improvisation total qui a une liste d'
incohérences aussi longue qu'une liste
de courses et c'est pas normal
donc c'est trouver un site à chaque fois
c'est trop facile de pointer les gens du
doigt sans jamais pointé les vrais
responsables qui sont les responsables
politiques
aurélien véron vous répondez quoi jeudi
dernier mais tout le monde a sa part de
responsabilité mais ça m'amuse quand
j'entends la planification mise en avant
par que le domaine de la santé c'est le
domaine le plus planifié de front vous
avez dans les hôpitaux français sont
1000 personnels qui ne sont pas des
soignants sont mises administrative qui
planifie le résultat de ce modèle de
santé avec des agences régionales de
santé
une haute autorité de la santé des
modules des comités théodule en tout
genre c'est que quand le virus est
arrivé
personne n'a su dire ce qu'il fallait
faire la planification ça aboutit
systématiquement à c'était le cas dans
la santé française à n'importe quoi
parce que le planificateur
il est irresponsable c'est jamais sont
jamais sa responsabilité
aujourd'hui le vous me parler
d'embauchés alors ça m'a même ça ça
m'amuse parce que rien ni m un
anesthésiste ses 12 ans d'études
vous pouvez pas juste claquer des doigts
et dire je veux que ça soit restée six
de plus ces douze ans c'est très long
on a vécu des dizaines plusieurs
décennies de numerus clausus
merci à vos amis socialistes qui
voulaient planifier la santé en disant
s'il ya moins de médecins il y aura
moins de malades c'est la grande loge
magnifique actrice mais ça marche pas
comme ça à la santé et donc aujourd'hui
le domaine de la santé a certainement
besoin d'un grand coup de ménage un bon
coup de balai dans la bureaucratie qui
gêne les personnels soignants
il faut mettre le paquet et non pas sur
cette bureaucratie médical qui planifie
résultat qui nous a mis dans l'ornière
pendant des mois mais plutôt sur les
personnels soignants qui connaissent
leur métier et qui besoin d'être
décentralisée de prendre des décisions
au niveau régional au niveau de chaque
hôpital d'une coordination clinique
privée hôpital médecine de ville
cette coordination elle se fait
librement les agences de santé l'ont
bloquée de la planification a ses
limites
après vous pourriez mettre le doigt sur
un responsable on est tous responsables
c'est pas les jeunes c'est certes un
jeune c'est pas l'état l'état a fait des
erreurs
ils ont aussi appris des responsabilités
les moments il le fallait le faire
les ont eu raison le confinement il n'y
a pas beaucoup de français à part ce
fonds sera soumise pour contester
l'utilité de ce compliment qui a permis
de passer un été et se rend compte que
ça marchait donc tout le monde est un
peu responsable
on fait des erreurs ces indemnisations
difficile moi je suis vigilante pour
l'avenir et donc je m'interroge encore
une fois sur cette méthode à l'avenir
pour l'instant on a des tests qui ne
marche pas donc depuis le mois de mars
on aurait pu y aura des tests qui marche
ou 48 heures en 24 heures aujourd'hui il
faut une semaine tu revends un résultat
les masques saillon les avenirs la
planification n'a pas marché parce que
là vous appelle la panification les
masques c'est pas d'unification qui a
marché ce sont les grandes surfaces
commerciales donc le marché a apporté
beaucoup plus vite des réponses
pratiques aux besoins des malades
la planification pour récupérer ses fers
les pharmaciens et les professions
médicales n'ont pas le droit de faire
des tests sans doute qu'on aurait
beaucoup plus de tests rendu en beaucoup
moins de temps qu aujourd'hui on va
revenir à cette idée de la solidarité
finalement qui a été mise en avant hier
par le président emmanuel macron un
couvre-feu pour être solidaire et
finalement qu'il n'y a pas de saturation
derrière des hôpitaux
quel cette solidarité là vous en pensez
quoi vous julie garnier qu'elle est
hypocrite
la vraie solidarité ça serait déjà de
rétablir lisf lisf vous savez c'est pas
n'importe quoi ces trois milliards vous
savez ce qu'on fait avec 3 milliards
mark rutte 60000 sociaux c'est pas mal
de recruter 60 mille soignants dans donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate c'est qu'à
chaque fois c'est toujours les mêmes qui
sont épargnés à qui on ne demande aucun
effort et l'effort repose sur qui
toujours sur les mêmes non il fallait
si vous payez mieux les soignants vous
verrez il n'y a pas besoin d'attendre 12
ans qui en a qui reviendront faire leur
métier original parce qu'il sait la
vérité c'est ya des soignants qui ont
démissionné parce qu'ils en avaient ras
le bol d'être mal payé
méprisé et qui étaient sous l'eau et qui
n'en pouvait plus voilà c'est ça la
réalité donc payer mieux les gens
offraient des conditions de travail
décentes 7 en sorte que justement on est
reconnu dans son travail ça c'est pas
rien et vous verrez que bah vous quand
vous êtes entrepreneur vous savez
débaucher dans les autres entreprises de
là c'est pareil juste reconnaissez les
gens à arrêter de les traiter comme
n'importe quoi arrêter de leur dire que
toute façon ce sont des bureaucrates et
qui ne servent à rien que les
fonctionnaires sont le trou de le trou
sociale de ce pays
c'est insupportable à force donc au bout
d'un moment quand on comprendra que
notre solidarité elle repose justement
sur ces services publics sur ces
enseignants sur ces soignants acquis à
chaque fois on ne donne on et
maltraitent on est mal paye et
d'ailleurs c'est pas nous qui le disons
ce sont les chiffres de l' ocde qui le
dise donc voyez le cd yeux c'est pas une
organisation communiste totalitaire 1
donc il me semble que il faut tout
simplement faire une vraie solidarité et
une solidarité qui justement met à
contribution sous qui en plus je vous
rappelle quand même que ces dix
dernières années
les milliardaires ont gagné plus de 430
9 %
c'est pas rien quand en douze années le
smic a augmenté de 12% voc les
dividendes eux ont augmenté de plus de
100% tout cas un moment quand on parle
de solidarité
j'aimerais qu'on
de racketter les pauvres j'aimerais
qu'on arrête de racketter les gens
vivront dans les urgences
j'aimerais qu'on arrête de racketter les
malades j'aimerais juste qu'on met à
contribution ceux qui sont les vrais
profiteurs de cette crise et qui à
chaque fois sont épargnés yarn il nous
reste quelques secondes
aurélien véron on vous laisse le mot de
la fin pour répondre à la solidarité
avec le fusil sur la tempe je sais pas
comment ça s'appelle mais moi je vais
passer autrement plus tôt la servitude
et les régimes tout fonctionné comme ça
en général de le payer extrêmement mal
et leurs enseignants et leurs
infirmières donc j'ai moyennement
confiance en vos méthodes et je rappelle
encore une fois que la bureaucratie de
la santé s'est elle compte de ce que
j'ai choisi un camp vous avez sont mille
administrative dans les hôpitaux plus
sûrs des dizaines de milliers de
fonctionnaires ou les agences régionales
et qu'elle a faim vous avez une crise
comme le co vide et que personne ne sait
quoi dire
vous avez la réponse de la planification
c'est un massacre donc il faut revenir à
des règles beaucoup plus souple beaucoup
plus flexible payer les gens ça veut
dire avoir des gens moins nombreux mais
mieux payés
ça veut dire le nettoyage le font ceux
qui sont derrière leur bureau pour payer
ceux qui sont devant les lits et qui
soignent les malades qui savent ce qui
pour faire en général qui sont pas
écoutés par leurs bureaucrates
donc effectivement un vrai modèle qui
paye des fonctionnaires qui sont au
contact des élèves au contact des
malades au contact dont la rue des
délinquants c'est eux qu'il faut payer
il faut un taux moins payer ceux qui
sont derrière des bureaux qui fonderait
d'après ce qu'ils demandent des
contrôles à tout le monde et qui
harcèlent et les enseignants parce que
les enseignants ont une vie
administrative qui est compliqué qui
harcèlent les médecins et les infirmiers
qui ont une vie administrative très
compliqué à cause de la bureaucratie
derrière eux qui ont la vie des
logiciels
voilà je pense qu'il ya un gros ménage à
faire dans l'administration pour rendre
des moyens à ce qu'ils font merci à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté le débat ce
soir merci avoue julie garnier porte
parole de la france insoumise merci à
vous aurélien véron conseiller paris
porte parole du groupe changer paris